the French Quarter a great place if you
want to see somebody get shot or summer
you want to get a good sandwich and
watch somebody get cut up or something
by a burglar or whatever you got to go
to the French Quarter and if you haven't
been to Jacksonville it's kind of like a
Ross Dress for Less but it's alive I was
just up in Tacoma last week in this cold
water country even in the bird baths you
see birds stop by check the water to can
cold
take off diet dehydration I caught a
bass it was shivering and you know in
Indiana
I think the Ku Klux Klan started there
and a lot of people think it was in the
south and it was actually in Indiana so
you know this is the kind of thing that
uh huh but you know other good stuff
started there too basketball so one
thing that was good for different
ethnicities and one thing that was bad
for different ethnicities so it's you
know it's definitely hit or miss out
there you know it's hit or miss Boston
yep hey it's Dan for mr. gang gang dude
I got pink out there in the Monongahela
once and I got a job one time over there
behind that giant eagle now to Buccos yo
w oh car downstairs blowing paint blow
in the sand trap on it Shannon don't
wanna come down man
let's hear more hey Theo this is Ashley
I'm calling from Tampa hey Ashley thank
you for calling for Tampa Tampa bad
zoning down there you know strip club
right next to a place where you could
get a boat or you know get a animal
euthanize dog all types of stuff Spanish
moss everything and Toronto dude is so
diverse let me tell you that if you're
racist you couldn't even figure out who
to hate this is the most diverse place
you ever seen man one dude said he was
jalapeno Mike what is that they got a
dude he was polish and Pomeranian some
dude said he was um
Serbian macchiato we got jaws 24 from
Cincinnati that's Chile country they
have Chile there they're famous for
Chile they have two types of Chile that
are popular one of them is disgusting
I've had that one on word and that's
Washington you got to probably do some
wild pit up in Washington get a rap
sheet
because it's mostly the woods you know
mostly a lot of you could chalk up to
mother nature I've been up to me and
it's a lot of people growing their own
weed arguing with the cops and the cops
are also at home growing their own weed
okay I spent some time off Islesboro
island out there john travolta country
when we had dinner with Kirstie Alley
one time when I was a child a friend of
mine knew her and also hid a bat with a
UM with a tennis racket so I've been
through some [ __ ] out there in Wisconsin
that's the dairy belt you'll step in
something outside you might go what is
that and it's just nothing that's a
little bit of 2% you'll see some stray
yogurt just kind of rolling down a
hillside Tampa Florida that's pirate
country a lot of deviant ex-husbands and
bad mustaches down there in Tampa
Baltimore good place to get crab and
murdered let's hear more Seattle tries
to hide it off in the suburbs I get like
it's not a real place but Tacomas out
there and they got they they call it the
Tacoma aroma in the air but I like that
come over here to Tacoma get a hit
people over there in Seattle y'all pet
and salmon and doing all of this [ __ ]
you go to Tacoma boy anything will
happen there was some drunk lady she ran
into a truck right walking then she
started fist fighting a dang Dodge Ram
so that's what's going on real over
there in Tacoma wow you know it's crazy
as my sister can't even read but what
does it have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one